oh man there's a noose or movie whatever
it'll be about I mean they've already
had him fighting Loki in the Dark Elves
what could possibly be next oh I know
maybe they'll mention that time that
Thor new pagina or better yet maybe
they'll tell the story of that time that
Thor helped Hitler kill Stalin yeah
those are the MCU movies that I'd be
really interested to see hello internet
welcome to film theory the show that
keeps digging until it finds the stuff
that everyone else is hoping you forget
after ruining Ant Man and spider-man I
think it was time for a change time to
tackle a superhero who isn't themed
after something you crush under your
boot that's right today we're talking
Thor Ragnarok and I'm happy to report
that my shameless wobbling at the feet
of Disney did finally get me into an
early preview of one of their movies
have no fear today's theory is a hundred
percent spoiler free now in the latest
trailer for Thor Ragnarok they tease a
moment that served as a running joke or
up movie voice activation required o
strongest Avenger let me try vana
welcome strongest Avenger oh what Thor
consistently claims that is the
strongest Avenger but gets undermined
time and time again by the Hulk
it's hilarious and it also got me
thinking of the two
would be the stronger Avenger obviously
the Quinn jet computer has been
programmed to think that Hulk is the
strongest but Thor is literally a God so
shouldn't he win the title Stanley
certainly seems to think so in a radio
interview asking about who would win in
a fight Stan went on record to say I
would have to say Thor because strongest
Hulk is he's still immortal but four is
one of the Norse gods so who's right
here the Stan Lee truly know his own
creation or when we prove today that
he's more out of touch than a parent
trying to understand what a rice gum is
is Thor right to feel slighted by the
computer or is it just stating a fact
that this arrogant Asgardian refuses to
accept it's time to settle this
superhuman grudge match once and for all
with the greatest superpower of them all
research first let me make it clear I
want to determine who is literally the
strongest not who would win in a fight
since that involves strategy and
fighting techniques I'm talking pound
for pound who is physically stronger
who's able to lift more and punch harder
so let's start at the very beginning
which I hear is a very good place to
start the comics across their mutual
fifty-five year history these two
Goliath's have gone toe-to-toe a lot so
maybe by seeing who wins in these fights
more often we can start to figure out
who is the stronger superhero their
first fight 1963's avenger number three
no clear winner okay their second fight
1965's journey into mystery number 112
no clear winner okay third time's a
charm
1971 the Submariner 35 no clear winner
defenders can draw Incredible Hulk 300
draw mighty for 489 draw by this point
you might be noticing a pattern the
comics want to keep the winner of this
battle more vague than a Scott Cawthon
storyline in nearly every matchup the
two either stalemate each other or the
US government comes in and drops a nuke
to stop the two from fighting
that's your taxpayer dollars at work
ladies and gentlemen however there are a
few pieces of evidence we can use hidden
across these battles in 1987's Mighty
Thor number 385 Hulk repeatedly says
that Thor can't beat him without his
hammer so
denies it and throws his hammer away
twice during the battle but it's only
once Mjolnir is back in play that he's
able to topple the whole that wouldn't
mean much on its own but in 2011 sphere
itself number five Thor confesses that
he could never be whole and it doesn't
seem like he's exaggerating either in
2012's Hulk smash Avengers number one
all the Avengers collectively work
together to try and hold the Hulk down
with Thor using the handle of Mjolnir to
pin Hulk's neck Hulk sends them all
flying giving us our first true piece of
evidence that in the moment he was
stronger than Thor as well as all the
other Avengers combined then again we
are talking about a guy who is
canonically defeated by a strategic box
of puppies so the title of strongest
Avenger might not be as prestigious as
it might initially sound okay so their
head-to-head battles might be a draw but
what about comparing their relative
feats of strength during Marvel's secret
Wars for a cosmic entity known as the
Beyonder sends a number of heroes and
villains to an artificial planet to bath
at one point the Beyonder drops a
mountain range on them and are not so
Jolly Green Giant literally shoulders
the burden while the others plan their
escape the mountain range is confirmed
to be two miles tall two miles of pure
rock tall and the cover itself says that
it weighs 150 billion tons that is three
times ten to the 14th power pounds of
rock on his shoulders which is
incredible but not nearly as incredible
as what we see in the Incredible Hulk
102 where he pulls a planet back
together with his bare hands he
literally grabs two tectonic plates and
Yanks them back together my favorite
part of this comic by the way is the
explanation for this he he shifted the
plates of course he did he's the Hulk
considering the weight of the Earth's
crust is about 6,200 times 10 to the
19th pounds and there are about 15 major
tectonic plates on earth each of those
plates
Hulk is moving is gonna add up to about
4.1 sextillion pounds and he's moving
two of them with his bare hands
good luck standing up to that one Thor
except he does it seems like he cans
toe-to-toe against this number in Thor
272 Thor and Loki encountered the giant
hood guard who challenges the Asgardians
to some rather unique challenges one of
which is to lift his cat no no you heard
that right
lift a cat and you all thought that the
plot of dark world was bad look at the
source material they're working with
here people in all seriousness this
story is based on Norse mythology and as
you may expect the cat isn't actually a
cat in both the comic and the myth the
cat is actually revealed to be a
disguised Midgard serpent
that probably doesn't mean a whole lot
to you don't worry it didn't mean a
whole lot to me either the serpent is
actually a massive snake also known as
your monk agender your mung vendor
commander whose sole purpose is
encircling the planet and destroying it
who's a bad kitty snake no treats for
you get in the corner more importantly
for our purposes though your banner is
massively heavy although we don't ever
get an exact weight for the serpent we
know that it has the mass necessary to
surround the entire Earth and destroy it
the force that it would take to destroy
Earth according to people who have spent
a great deal of time thinking about
destroying the earth would be about 2.2
4 times 10 to the 24th pounds of force
although Thor fails the test he does
manage to lift one of the cat's legs off
the ground a feat that is apparently
impressive to guard the Giants I don't
know I pick up all four of skips legs
all the time and he's getting fatter by
the day anyway that means Thor is
exerting the equivalent of five
septillion pounds of force a full three
more digits than Hulk pulling tectonic
plates
so maybe Thor and Stanley are right to
think that Thor is in fact the strongest
Avenger but here's the thing
comics are weird I mean we just talked
about how Thor is strongest beat in the
comics is getting a single cat paw off
the ground strength scaling in the
comics is very different from strength
scaling in the movies and honestly this
is film theory I'm more interested in
the movies anyway an MCU operates by a
different standard a world where Thor
isn't a Hitler supporter as Stan Lee
said in the comic universe Thor is
literally a god but in the MCU Odin
makes a point to make it clear that
they're not gods they're mortals just
like us we are not gods we're born we
live we die as humans do give or take
five thousand years and well as
Guardians have proven themselves to be
quite handy in the MCU like in the
original Thor she now puts him in a
completely different vein as the
Asgardians from earth-616
that's the main Marvel Comics universe
for those of you who are unaware of
top-level geek speek so to get our final
answer let's focus on moments of
strength from the movies to determine
whether ragnaroks computer has chest a
big troll our first baseline measurement
is Iron Man across the 17 films of the
MCU at this point we've seen Tony Stark
take on both Hulk and
Thor so the relative performance against
it will be a good benchmark the battle
against Thor happens in the original
Avengers movie during the battle Thor
uses his lightning powers to zap the
Iron Man suit which has the reverse
effect he wanted and charges the armor
up to 475 percent power calamar four
hundred percent capacity how about that
yeah sure about that Jarvis then why
does it say four seventy-five on Tony's
readout anyway Iron Man comes out of
this battle alive Jerry you could say
Thor may have been holding back but he
was at minimum trying to stop Tony and
ultimately fail compare that now to Hulk
vs Iron Man in age of Ultron here Tony
uses his special Hulkbuster armor a suit
that is powered by 11 reactor cores even
with 11 times the output of one normal
suit Tony still couldn't overpower Hulk
so we got to give the point to hold and
then what about Hulk and Thor's first
cinematic battle here's Thor struggling
to hold back Hulk's one arm but then
here's footage of Thor completely
destroying Hulk mere seconds later with
mule deer' which is something we haven't
taken into consideration yet the hammer
why are we spending so much time
calculating and comparing when chip the
owner give us our answer outright Thor
can lift mule near when no one else can
thus he should be the strongest right
well not exactly you see if this were
the comics that might be the case comic
book Mjolnir has a specific mechanism by
which it works as unworthy people
attempt to lift it it starts to gain
mass that leaves open the slim but very
real possibility of someone else being
able to lift it
in fact Hulk is able to the hammer gains
mass slower than Hulk gains strength as
he increasingly gets more angry trying
to lift the darn thing his strength
eventually overtakes it and he becomes
one of the few to be able to wield
Mjolnir in the MCU however we know meal
there isn't actually based on weight but
rather on Odin's enchantment
this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the balance it's not an issue of
mass but rather worthiness the hammer
allows itself to be lifted by those
deemed worthy when Thor was on the
naughty list
he couldn't budge the thing it's only
after he's back on the nice list that
he's able to lift it again
so ability to pick up the only ER is a
moot point but the hammer itself can
help us crown our final winner back in
the Avengers Thor goes toe to toe with
the big guy and isn't holding himself
back after meal near knocks Hulk down
Hulk attempts to pick it up and
retaliate but learns as we all know that
the owner will only move for those that
are deemed worthy the result is Hulk
pulling on it with all his might and
then this remember in Thor was trying to
lift mule near I don't remember his feet
sinking into any rock after doing some
calculations on the size of Hulk's feet
on the strength of the tarmac on the
shield chip to dig himself into a floor
like this Hulk would have had to output
three million seven hundred sixty eight
thousand pounds of force to dent the
asphalt floors per individual foot now
compare that to Thor's big moment of
strength from the movies crushing Iron
Man's arm at the end of the original
Iron Man Tony corrects a little fallacy
about his suit there's not technically
accurate machines our golden boy he's
not iron man he's gold titanium alloy
man in 2016 a team at Rice University
discovered a real gold titanium alloy
that was four times harder than steel
four times according to Wikipedia
structural steel can take a force of
about 36 thousand psi before it begins
to fall or break so that would mean an
alloy four times the strength could take
about a hundred and forty four thousand
pounds of pressure per square inch in
order for a hand about the size of
Thor's to output that same level of
pressure to crush Iron Man's gauntlet it
would translate to three million four
hundred fifty six thousand pounds of
force
three hundred thousand pounds of force
under what we know holds output of one
foot to be so any way you slice it Stan
Lee is just outright wrong it's easy to
assume that a god-like superhero would
be the most overpowered but most of that
is coming from you'll near itself but
Ragnarok plays as a joke at Thor's
expenses just factually true based on
what's said in the comics their feats of
strength logical comparisons and just
flat-out math and science there is no
denying that Hulk is the strongest
Avenger well until we factor vision into
all this then Hulk
better start watching out but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cuts